[Musique]
je voudrais simplement d'abord commencé
par
une interrogation qui est celle que
chacun de nouveaux fonds depuis sa
naissance se constitue une bulle qui est
la représentation du monde dans lequel
il est qui lui vient de son éducation de
son milieu de sa culture bien évidemment
et au fond chacun de nous vit dans un
monde et c'est avec ce monde qui
l'intérêt agit il a souvent bien du mal
toute façon
il a ses propres valeurs il axe il a du
mal il cessa ce qu'on appelait depuis le
début sa zone de confort
d'ailleurs on retrouve ça sur facebook
sur facebook on a des amis et puis on
aime beaucoup voir ses amis vous dire
like vous laïque et j'aime mais si vous
faites bien attention
like like me c'est comme moi d'ailleurs
ce qui vous agressent on a tôt fait de
les éjecter de manière à rester dans son
monde avec ceux qui nous ressemblent
on peut retrouver là-dedans aussi
le le mythe de la caverne de platon
qui est à dire des gens qui sont au fond
de la caverne et qui vivent quelque
chose qui n'est pas la réalité parce que
ce sont des ombres projetées par la
lumière qui est derrière eux certains
d'entre eux prennent conscience qu'au
fond ils ne vivent pas la réalité et
donc il tente de sortir de la caverne
mais certains sont éblouis par la
lumière tellement forte qu'ils préfèrent
de nouveau rentré au fond de la caverne
alors c'est ça la vraie pour le vrai
problème sommes nous capables
aujourd'hui de réaliser que notre monde
c'est le monde que nous avons construit
et qui ne représente pas la réalité et
sommes-nous capables
au fond de sortir de ce monde pour
affronter les autres car seuls des
autres dans la relation avec les autres
les autres me permettent de me remettre
en question est est ce que je peux
accepter le migrant est ce que je peux
accepter celui qui ne vit pas de la même
façon que moi celui qui a une autre
culture suis-je capable de m'ouvrir à un
monde beaucoup plus large que celui dans
lequel je suis
j'ai eu toute une carrière militaire
pendant 28 ans je suis parti dans de
nombreuses zones de conflit que ce soit
les guerres en afrique ce soit le liban
que ce soit des situations de
catastrophe en algérie boumerdès que ce
soit aussi à mexico ou ailleurs que ce
soit au liban j'ai été en situation de
guerre
mais la guerre du golfe a été pour moi
très marquante
elle était très marquante parce que
pendant six mois les forces françaises
étaient en plein désert d'arabie
saoudite
nous étions complètement isolé j'étais
dans une antenne médico-chirurgical
aérotransportable c'est à dire nous
étions onze en plein désert à côté d'un
hôpital de campagne où ils étaient
beaucoup plus nombreux mais nous vivions
à part
six mois d'attentes dans le désert
six mois à ne rien faire pour un médecin
la guerre il a fait tous les jours dans
son hôpital et là on nous demandait
d'attendre que lille me taire face la
guerre pour éventuellement prendre en
charge des victimes
six mois au fond j'ai pris conscience de
l'inanité même de ce que nous étions en
train de faire être là c'est à dire que
nous allions payé peut-être de notre vie
pour le pétrole pour les américains pour
le koweït
j'avais cinq enfants en bas âge je me
suis rendu compte que je n'étais pas
prêt à ce sacrifice n'est pas du tout et
donc ça me mettait dans une colère
pendant six mois une colère très forte
l'impression d'avoir été pris au piège
je pouvais penser que je pouvais donner
ma vie pour mon pays bien évidemment
mais je n'ai pas entrevue que je pouvais
donner ma vie pour
des intérêts économiques
six mois de difficultés je dois le dire
six mois de violences et moi
d'indignation
des difficultés bien sûr rentrer en
contact avec nos familles pour nous tous
qui étions dans le désert
il fallait user de mille façons aller
chez des épiciers trouver un village
arabe et voir si l'épicier vous
permettez éventuellement de prendre de
pouvoir communiquer avec les siens
et puis est arrivé le mois de février
1991 et là nous avons reçu l'ordre de
rempiler toutes nos affaires et de
partir en direction de l'irak parce que
allait commencer justement l'invasion
terrestre
donc nous sommes retrouvés à 2,3
kilomètres de la frontière irakienne nos
structures sanitaires
avec l'ordre de nous mettre en rang en
colonnes le lendemain matin à 6 heures
il était prévu que les iraniens puissent
utiliser du nouveau toxiques
et donc il fallait prendre un antidote
toutes les six heures à une heure du
matin la garde tape à la porte de mon
ambulance où je dormais à l'intérieur je
prends le comprimé
je me rallonge
on avait prévu 10% de pertes le premier
jour des antennes chirurgicales sont à
20 km de la ligne de front
7 % le deuxième jour 3 % le troisième
jour je me recouche
je trouve pas le sommeil mais d'un seul
coup un sentiment de liberté déjà en moi
un sentiment de joie qui m'envahit
totalement
d'un seul coup
j'ai accepté l'idée de mourir le
lendemain
d'un seul coup j'ai pris conscience que
j'étais libéré en fin de cette idée qui
me enfin de tous ces six mois qui ce qui
me mettaient en colère
à ce moment là très précisément j'ai
vécu quelque chose de très intenses et
le lendemain matin je me suis mis dans
le convoi et nous sommes partis vers
l'irak les tirs de l'artillerie passer
au dessus de nos têtes sur le ford à
salman
et j'avais mis enia à fond
et je suis parti comme ça
depuis cet instant
ce sentiment vite par rapport à la mort
ne m'a plus jamais quittés
plus jamais quittés mais ce que j'avais
réalisé au même temps
c'est que ma vie
celle que je croyais être ma vie mon
monde je m'étais complètement fourvoyés
pour voiliers sur le plan affectif
fourvoyer dans le monde travaillent
fourvoyé
et j'ai pris conscience en même temps
que nous n'avons qu'une seule vie
et que si nous ne
choisissons pas notre vie c'est les
autres qui la choisissent pour nous
alors à ce moment là j'ai pris la
décision de vivre ma vie et il s'agit
pas d'un problème de bien ou de mal dans
les choix que nous faisons mais est ce
que c'est juste
et est ce que c'est vrai pour moi c'est
la question fondamentale que l'on doit
se poser à chaque fois que l'on a à
rester sur le chemin du sens de sa vie
est ce que c'est juste
et est ce que c'est vrai et non pas est
ce que c'est bien et est-ce que c'est
mal
il s'est trouvé bien évidemment que le
sens de ma vie c'était soigné puisque
j'étais médecin médecins et spécialisée
surtout en situation de guerre et j'ai
quitté l'armée et je suis parti en
humanitaire est d'abord en syrie pendant
dix ans
mais compétences universitaires c'est la
médecine de guerre j'ai aidé mes
collègues syrien en créant quatre
centres de formation en syrie nous avons
mis en place douze courts efforts mais
trente quatre mille personnes
infirmiers médecins
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien sûr à chaque fois c'était au risque
de ma vie il y a eu la période d'arrêt
chili a eu la période à l'australie a eu
ses périodes là mes camarades en
toujours été près de moi pour me
protéger si ce qui avait été nécessaire
bien sûr il ya eu des périodes
extrêmement difficile de passer sous les
barbelés en pleine nuit avec des
passeurs et des cisailles et puis
d'avoir l'ipod avec bocelli qui se d'un
seul coup se met à chanter en pleine
nuit tout près du poste frontière turque
bien sûr il ya eu des périodes où la
pluie des tellement intense que au
niveau des tchèques bank al- nostra
n'est jamais sorti justement au niveau
des charpentes pour nous arrêter et nous
avons fait 180 km dans les zones tenues
par al nostra et de là je me suis sentie
totalement protégé bien sûr dans le
premier hôpital a été bombardé au 48e
heures et je me suis jetée par terre
parce qu'à 4 heures du matin le muezzin
se met à chanter ce qui me réveille
brutalement et je me jette par terre et
tout l'hôpital explose bien sûr il ya eu
toutes ces périodes bien sûr il y a eu
toutes ces périodes mais jo j'étais dans
le sens de ma vie jamais je n'ai pris la
décision de me retirer
et au même temps c'était de soigner
parce que j'étais le professeur alors il
fallait au même temps leur apprendre à
trier c'est extrêmement difficile
trier en situation de guerre et en
situation dégradée c'est faire des choix
et ce qui le plus souvent vient hanter
les nuits c'est bien sûr un certain
nombre de jeunes enfants de gens pour
qui j'ai pris la décision de ne pas
l'espagne et de les laisser mourir bien
sûr que c'était difficile au même temps
de rentrer en france et de se retrouver
dans mon service de réanimation de la
politique de gentilles et d'avoir tous
les moyens pour des personnes souvent en
fin de vie avec des pathologies
chroniques qui avait été opéré pour des
cancers au stade terminal et de se
rendre compte que j'avais tous les
moyens pour leur permettre de survivre
alors que là bas je laisser mourir des
jeunes
parce que malheureusement il n'y avait
pas de possibilité de dialyse passe
positivité de réanimation pas de
possibilité pas de suffisamment de
matériel de notre côté il y avait toute
cette jeunesse qui mouraient et de
l'autre côté il y avait ces personnages
équipe bénéficiez de tous je ne fait pas
le distinguo j'ai trouvé cela
profondément injuste au fond cette
situation et sa mamie ça me mettait dans
une situation de colère qui fait que
pendant deux semaines et dépressif
pendant deux semaines dans mon service
de réanimation il était bon de ne pas me
parler le temps que je puisse réussir à
absorber mais j'ai fini par quitter
l'hôpital considérant que c'était
impossible pour moi de continuer comme
ça et en 2015 j'ai préféré sortir de
l'hôpital bien sûr il y avait aussi au
même temps les réfugiés et je les avais
vus ces réfugiés syriens à l'intérieur
de la syrie à l'extérieur par millions
vivent dans des conditions terribles et
qui ont tenté de venir en europe et j'ai
vu la manière dont nous avons accueilli
ces gens combien nous sommes ouverts à
recevoir les ukrainiens comment
avons-nous réagi à l'arrivée de 1
million de syriens qui fuient et la
violence de la guerre toutes les armes
ont été utilisées tous les hôpitaux
étaient systématiquement bombardé par
les russes toutes les armes et je parle
y compris des neurotoxiques qui ont été
utilisés contre cette population
syrienne qui a été véritablement
martyrisé durant toutes ces années et
nous avons laissé faire et nous avons
tourné le regard à côté partout j'ai
essayé d'être en même temps un témoin de
ce que je voyais pas ce qui était
difficile pour moi de rester je suis
parti à new york je suis parti aux états
unis je suis parti à genève pour
dénoncer cette situation de crimes de
guerre de crimes contre l'humanité
maintenant bien évidemment on envoie des
des fonctionnaires de l'onu pour
justement vérifier ces crimes de guerre
en ukraine mais en syrie pendant dix ans
nous avons laissé faire et nous avons
regardé ailleurs bien évidemment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y as pour moi un sens profond
avec toutes ces années que ce soit
l'afrique que ce soit l'asie que ce soit
le moyen orient c'est de bien comprendre
qu'il n'ya qu'une seule humanité
et au contraire toutes les différences
de notre humanité font notre richesse
véritablement est profondément je ne
peux vous appeler qu'à sortir de votre
confort de sortir de votre monde de vous
ouvrir au monde tel qu'il est d'aller
vers les autres pour essayer de vous
enrichir même temps des différences qui
peuvent exister
je peux vous invitez si vous voulez à
vivre votre propre vie ne vous laissez
pas imposé par les autres ce que vous ne
voulez pas
ayez le courage en même temps
d'affronter cela
véritablement
et plus que tout je vous le dis encore
vivez votre vie car sinon
qu'il arrivera pour vous je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]